but the thing you know actually like I
had this big kind of breakthrough with
um with kovid because it was kind of
this this it it did something to uh how
I viewed a lot of these things uh and it
became so simple it was kind of like
okay uh a friend has covid because this
was the first time it really felt like
this friends would be sick you'd still
hang out with them you don't give a [__]
you know before kovid someone's sneezing
oh what are you sick I'm not gonna stay
away from you I don't give a [__] look
you feel like we're just talking about
that feel Invincible you might not shake
their hand somebody maybe I don't even
open right I don't think I had any
restrictions I didn't give a [__] you
were hand changing oh you know like I
think I was too because if you were
Howie Mandel doing this we were like
what is this guy how are you it felt
weird now we're all like yeah you know
we all have rules yeah but I remember it
really hit me and I was like oh wow like
okay my friend has kovid he's still my
friend I love him but I can't be in the
same room with him right now because he
has kovid I gotta wait my friend is
isn't covet right my friend is not the
coronavirus my friend has the
coronavirus my friend is amazing he
currently has the coronavirus in two
weeks I can see him okay my friend is
greedy yeah is my friend greedy or does
he have this really have greedy on him
like is he Afflicted with greed right
right so so it's like you know what I
mean like like that started to be like I
was like oh whoa no my friend currently
has agreed yeah he's not greedy he's
good
if I were to sit and think about his
life I could and only God knows but
let's just say because I actually do
need to make some judgment calls in
order to protect myself you know there's
this whole I remember there's this
podcast I listened to I cannot remember
what it was but there's this podcast I
listened to that was like you know our
brains need to know this is a couch and
not a bomb so that we can sit on it
right so on some level we are making
judgment calls that we have to make in
order to put ourselves in positions to
feel healthy and feel happy and feel all
the things we want to feel so I I can
make a level of saying my friend there's
something going on with greed I'm not
going to try and connect all the dots
but maybe I've seen enough to say
there's something going on with greed
but is he I'll never say that maybe he
has greed so what does that mean well
maybe that means I'm not gonna bring him
to my house because maybe he'll look at
my [__] in some way right that feels
weird right and that means I just gotta
meet with him if we're gonna hang out we
hang out outside we hang out in a coffee
shop you know so there's certain people
that you're like oh they have something
going on right that might need to change
like how I interact with them in order
for us to both access the most loving
the most merciful the most amazing part
so that other stuff doesn't get in the
way right and that's how I've really
viewed because I had all these
friendships that were kind of
complicated where I was like man like
why do I feel this why do I feel that
but I know I love him and it just
started to become clear I was like he's
good
we are all good
and then maybe it's like oh right now he
has jealousy right now he has anger and
I can kind of only God knows but I can
kind of suppose why those things happen
so now that I know that what are the
rules for how I'm going to interact so
that I'm not bitter and so that I'm not
walking around hurt and so that I can
appreciate like the love that I do have
you're separating the person from the
the symptom yeah my mind I framing is a
spiritual illness you know there's
something going on like in the Unseen
that they're what gave it to him it
probably wasn't just him he didn't want
it going out licking that's such a good
point it's so important yeah I don't
think anyone wants to be this one no I
don't think no one wants to be angry I
would say he's scared like to me it's
always it always comes down to some
feeling of unsafety yes or you know you
just don't feel
okay in your body you don't feel okay in
the world you you're you know how
complicated it can get in here yeah and
it comes out as like if I had more money
yeah I could finally protect myself yeah
or if I was big and scary I could keep
all that other people away from me I
mean it's it's a cliche you see it in
movies it's like the scary guy that just
needs love sorry the story is so boring
guys but like it turns out I didn't make
this up but everything is either love or
asking for it it's like the scary guy is
asking for love and I know we think that
just means being nice yeah [__] that
[__] A lot of people are turned off by
just phony nice just kind of like I want
to Werther's original that's not love
yeah what Fred Rogers was doing that's
more like love it's about space can you
give them space maybe the most loving
thing I can do to you if you if you had
anger yeah was to let you be angry yes
you know what I mean not not just being
like let's get a cupcake yes where did I
learn that a [__] commercial right
for Hostess right that's not love and
that's we're back to Consumers no no but
and that's so important what you're
saying too because it's like even in the
framing that I was kind of providing
it's not like it's not like if I know
you're angry I can't be around you it's
more like I think the the the intention
I'm having is like if I know your anger
is so overriding that there's nothing
like that I can do then maybe I'm gonna
treat you in a different way but also
it's like let's create the space for
people to just be angry and to do what
they need to do just so you don't feel
weird there's a lot of times in my life
where I go this is gone I always quote
this line from Lord of the Rings I go
this is beyond my skill to heal yeah I
just go like yeah I I can't I could give
you a lot of space right but right now
this is toxic why do I have the capacity
it's just a it's like the air rating
there's just a little too much smoke
here yeah let's let you ride the sound
and by the way it might be just because
I'm busy that day yeah like it might
just be actually I could totally handle
like how much of a dumpster fire you are
just on Saturday like you know what I
mean like I just can't do this [__] this
like this Tuesday it's really busy but
actually like all these [__]
Shenanigans yeah no problem let's just
do it not now not today like I could do
this on Saturday yeah and if you can't
wait till Saturday and you think now I'm
the devil because I made you wait four
days to lose your mind in front of me
right then well now that's on you that's
not on me
[Music]
where are you